who knew that putting Dracula on a boat
would go so poorly Universal's newest
stab at reimagining Dracula has arrived
but what does the ending of the last
Voyage of the Demeter mean for a
possible franchise future
before unpacking the film's tense finale
there are some important elements that
influence the fates of the characters
and their final bout with Dracula when
the monster emerges each night he
targets one crew member draining their
blood so he can regain his power and
strength
in the night it rings our blood that he
is on this ship
picks off the crew one by one Dracula
goes from being a frail corpse crawling
out of the Shadows to a fearsome Beast
with devastating power not only can
Dracula turn the crew members into his
mindless minions just by biting them but
once he has consumed enough blood he can
grow wings and can fly by the time the
crew comes to terms with the reality
that they're being hunted by a monster
there's only a handful of them left and
they've been mentally and physically
worn down they've witnessed most of
their companions be slaughtered or
turned against them by Dracula and
Captain Elliott has even lost his
grandson Toby to the Beast however crew
member Clemens is able to Rally those
who remain to form a new plan that'll
kill Dracula and keep him from reaching
the mainland but their plan to leave
Dracula stuck on the sinking Demeter
doesn't go as planned and leads to
unimaginable bloodshed
although Clemens plan to use Anna
Dracula's personal feeding source as
bait to lure the creature out makes
sense when he explains it Dracula also
quickly catches on to what they're up to
Dracula not only kills most of the
remaining crew leaving only Clemens and
Anna alive but he causes so much chaos
and destruction on the ship that it is
now barreling towards the mainland
eventually Dracula has Clemens in his
claws and is on the verge of killing him
until Anna steps in and frees him this
also causes one of the masts to fall
apart and pin Dracula into the middle of
the ship unfortunately the monster is
able to break free before the ship
crashes into the mainland and flies away
while Clemens and Anna float on debris
just offshore while Clemens is hopeful
that the two of them can make it to
safety Anna's eyes turning pale
signifies that she succumbed to
Dracula's bite and will burst into
flames when the Sun rises even though
Clemens performed a blood transfusion on
her it only delayed the inevitable
Clemens is crushed by this realization
but Anna has accepted her and thanks
Clemens for helping her fight back
against Dracula without fear she sits
atop some debris and floats away from
Clemens burning to death slowly when the
Sun hits her skin
although the newspaper headlines seen in
the final moment state that there were
no survivors aboard the Demeter we come
to learn that there are actually two
Clemens and Dracula Clemens has made it
to Shore and is now the only surviving
crew member of the ship while in England
Clemens searches for Dracula who he
believes is still out there somewhere
and he has given some direction as to
where the creature could be Clemens has
now made it to his life's goal to hunt
and kill Dracula so that the world can
be rid of this monster but he is unaware
that he's closer than he thinks to his
vampiric enemy Clemens hears the
knocking code used on the ship and feels
that it's coming from Dracula himself as
a form of taunting suddenly Dracula is
shown hiding his horrid face under some
clothes and holding the cane that
Clemens found in his coffin on the ship
Dracula passes by Clemens causing him to
leave his chair and follow him onto the
streets now neither Dracula nor Clemons
is afraid to make their presence known
to each other and their Newfound rivalry
begins
when the crew talks about what they plan
to spend the money earned from the trip
on Clemens delivers a vastly different
answer instead of wanting to spend it on
a new place to live or other Pleasures
he says he doesn't care about the money
and hopes to gain a better understanding
of the world from his travels although
he's scoffed at by most of the crew
there's a deeper more personal reason
behind this that plays into Clemens
pursuit of Dracula at the end when
further explaining his experience as a
black man Clemens talks about how he's
been looked over simply because of the
color of his skin
you dress like a learned man University
of Cambridge I know my way around the
boat
his getting a great education and being
a highly high-least doctor he was
he was right rejected for being black
causing him to become disillusioned by
people and the world this explains why
Clemens is so obsessed with exploring
and trying to gain a better
understanding of the world this mindset
also influences his interest in Dracula
a being that goes against his more
logical thinking and scientific views
now that Clemens knows that this
monstrous entity exists in the world he
wishes to understand its motives and
Origins so that he can defeat it and
prove himself to those who have doubted
him
the ending of Demeter also establishes a
pretty Grim reality for the world and
Dracula's appearance is a bad Omen for
Humanity not only is Dracula free and
living amongst the humans but so far no
one knows how to kill him even though
Clemens survived his fight against
Dracula on the Demeter he isn't aware of
how to defeat the vampire since Anna
didn't have the answer and none of the
weapons they used did anything further
if something as monstrous as Dracula
exists who knows what other Horrors and
evil creatures could exist in this world
too evil is walking around freely and
this could have damning consequences
however there are people like Clemons
who are willing to put everything on the
line to stop evil entities like Dracula
Clemens is portrayed as the Van Helsing
surrogate in this story and he pledges
his life to find and kill Dracula no
matter what it takes even when Clemens
is near death fighting Dracula he shows
that he isn't afraid of him and his
further pursuit of him is meant to act
as a reminder of how evil can and should
be fought against while there are
powerful entities out there that
represent the same kind of evil that
Dracula does there's always a way to
fight back
perhaps the biggest question posed by
the end of the film is whether we could
see more of this world given how this
film concludes there's certainly room
for a sequel or even a prequel to be
made with Clemens now on a lifelong
mission to kill Dracula a sequel could
see these two at each other's throats
again Clemens could be seen trying to
help another Community that's been
terrorized by Dracula or searching for
answers on how to kill this demonic
entity we could also possibly get a
prequel that fleshes out Dracula's
backstory or show Dracula controlling
Anna's Village given that the film is
set in the world of Bram Stoker's
Dracula other installments could easily
be created to adapt other parts of the
novel and further flesh out this world
while the film has clear goals for its
future there are things that could keep
it from reaching them the first obstacle
the film needs to overcome is it's
opening weekend at the box office it
releases at a time when both Barbie and
Oppenheimer still have a hold over the
box office and there's plenty of
competition from the summer Blockbusters
the early projections for Demeter range
from about 6 to 11 million which
wouldn't put it in Striking Distance of
either film based on what they're
projected to earn the film will
desperately need some good word of mouth
and strong legs to have a good box
office run the next factor in Demeter
being a success is if moviegoers like it
critics so far haven't been too fond of
the film but the audience is often the
driving force behind a film's success
the last hurdle for Demeter is the
competition from other vampire films
including another from Universal
themselves
eternals director Chloe Zhao has a
Dracula film on the way for Universal
and Pablo Lorraine's vampire film El
Conde is coming to Netflix in September
so there's a lot of competition that
could steal the film's Thunder and keep
it from its future and ambitions it's no
secret that Universal has been doing
everything it can to bring its classic
monsters back into the Limelight for
Years After the Dark Universe joined the
other failed cinematic universes
Universal faced an uphill struggle
however through films like the Invisible
Man and Renfield they've seen that there
are ways to bring their monsters back
without the need for a connected
Cinematic Universe Demeter isn't
explicitly Universal's attempt to bring
one of their classic monsters back to
life but it could easily be seen as a
way for Dracula's cinematic Legacy to
continue
do exist
exists since Renfield fell flat at the
box office the door is wide open for
another Dracula story to become
Universal's next big horror franchise
focused on the character with the
closing moments of Demeter seeing
Clemens begin his pursuit of Dracula the
story could easily continue in a sequel
while recent depictions of Dracula have
highlighted some of his more Charming
characteristics or put a comedic spin on
his presence Demeter takes the character
back to his horror Roots instead of
being seen as this unsuspecting charmer
with a hypnotizing power Dracula is
shown here to be more of an escaped
demon from Hell his teeth are disfigured
and sharpened to quickly draw blood from
his victims and he has a pale emaciated
look by the time Dracula reaches his
final form at the end of the film he
looks even more demonic
evil that appears as a man when it wants
to hide its true nature and that night
he feeds on the blood of the innocent
however what's most interesting about
this portrayal of Dracula is that he
doesn't change his look when trying to
hide among humans when he is shown in
the final moments of the film he's just
wearing clothes that slightly obscure
his face to help him blend in this
suggests that instead of using charm and
Suave looks to control those around him
this Dracula relies more on fear
intimidation and force to control others
a relatively fresh take on a classic
monster
along with a new physical depiction of
Dracula the ending of Demeter also
establishes some interesting new Mythos
surrounding the character and his new
pursuer Clemens with this Dracula using
fear and intimidation to maintain his
power we get a more beastly monster who
views his victims as disposable sources
of food rather than people he's much
more dangerous than ever before and the
minions he creates with the virus from
his bite are much more violent and
destructive than ever before when
olgaren gets possessed he's shown to be
very zombie-like and will go to any
length to do Dracula's bidding let's not
forget the fact that anyone with
Dracula's blood in them will be consumed
by Flames by the time morning comes
around further evidence that becoming
Dracula's minion is deadlier than ever
in Clemens we get a new type of Van
Helsing rather than have a background as
a hunter or someone who's been tormented
by Dracula for many years his Feud with
Dracula is fresh and his background as a
doctor gives him new ways of fighting
the monster's control these elements
give the film a sense of familiarity but
a newness as well and the ending puts
its own spin on the classic Mythos in a
way that feels exciting and interesting